hi
i'm dan scanlon director of onward i
wanted to share
a clip of one of my favorite scenes from
the movie
and it includes commentary from myself
and producer corey ray
talking about the genesis of the scene
where the idea came from
and what it means to the rest of the
movie and how it essentially kicks off
the adventure these two brothers have
trying to meet their
deceased father for the first time a
little setup of the scene
ian has just come back from a really bad
day at school
it's his birthday and he is missing his
um deceased father uh more than ever
thanks for watching
mom mom
this scene was written by jason headley
a writer on the film and
it was loosely inspired by a
a story again in my life with uh my
father we had found a
a tape of him um because
uh growing up all the videos i had or
well they were films
of my dad there was no sound so i had
never heard his
voice before and then when my brother
and i were about the age of ian and
barley
an aunt and uncle sent us an audio tape
that they said they think
his voice might be on so my family and i
played it
and we're listening to the tape and
little by little my dad is always out of
the room they're always referring to him
and saying oh he just went to the store
to get stamps and
the tape is nearly running out and
finally
they corner him and they say you know
say something into the machine bill
and he says hi and then they say well
say something else
so they know you can talk and he says
bye
and that was it that was all we got
hello and goodbye
but again to my brother and i it was
like super magical and it was
really wonderful and it was also a big
inspiration for the film and
yeah it really was yeah when you brought
the tape in and we played it for the
crew and it brought everybody to tears
and it was just
hearing those two words and knowing the
impact that it had on the two of you
even though it was just those two words
and have you hear you talking about how
um even in those two words you could
kind of
hear how you were like him or how yeah
who he was
he was very boisterous on the hello
which told me he's a nervous person he's
not used to talking to people and then
very shy in the on the goodbye
realizing oh he's like me awkward and
shy
but really that's what the movie is it's
one brother asking for a hello and
another
brother asking for a goodbye and i never
really
put it together that way but that is
kind of what they're going for exactly
you